there is no other team in the world like
t1 this could be a 20-minute game for sk
telecom they will be the season three
world champions to wear a t1 uniform is
to feel the weight of an unmatched
legacy coup tigers are falling skt will
be your first ever two-time world
champions but despite that success it
hasn't always been easy to cheer for t1
this is it the greatest team in the
history of league of legends taken down
by the greatest team europe has ever
produced and so the greatest dynasty in
league of legends did something else
that no esports team had done they
managed an astonishing rebuild with the
greatest player ever as their foundation
we'll be able to pick it up and that is
going to be the end of this t1 are your
spring 2022 victor with the greatest
dynasty ever behind them it's up to
faker and t1 to forge an even brighter
future this is the story of t1 league of
legends
sk telecom didn't begin with league of
legends their starcraft brood war roster
included icons like boxer and i love and
the team forged a rivalry with kt that
spanned over a decade but league of
legends was a new battlefield for skt
and they came out swinging in late 2012
and early 2013 they signed their first
two lineups in the title the two rosters
that eventually became known as sk
telecom t1s and k
skt1s was ostensibly the organization's
main roster a five stack previously
known as eat sleep game led by former
azubu frost captain reapered skt1k was
the development roster featuring three
notable rookies in bengi piglet and
faker but surprisingly skt's main roster
struggled throughout the year while
their rookie team flourished he knows
it's over champion summer is over sk
telecom coming back after being two down
and the only thing more surprising than
t1k's ascent over their sister team was
their utter dominance on the world stage
now kane gonna be the target exhaust
goes down but it won't make a difference
especially he's going to try and chase
down faker here but with impact to get
that taunt down willy howard
faker he's still alive charms gonna like
not swim
able to walk away baker is still running
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
he's got the shockwave still alive and
there is the shockwave coming down but
faker so very low expansion dive bacon's
still alive
comes in kate's trying to get the kill
he does get the kill this does not look
good for royal this doesn't exist
crescendo catches all of them it's a
double for impact they get on the
fountain sk telecom are just rolling
through the nexus turrets are
potentially gonna go down this could be
a 20 minute game for sk telecom they
will be the season three world champions
here at the staples center
faker and his team managed to win worlds
the very same year they were formed and
in doing so solidify the beginning of
korean international dominance then in
champions winter skt1k rolled through
the rest of korea without dropping a
single game
a little bit there as well but that is
it they're turning under the nexus and
sk telecom has done the impossible there
is a perfect season for sk telecom t1k
but unfortunately after a rough 2014
both teams failed to qualify for worlds
that year there's the first nexus turret
there's the second and there goes the
nexus logic shield is going the world
in the aftermath of the loss riot
abolished sister teams so the rosters
combined into a unified sk telecom t1
marin bengi faker easy hoon bang and
wolf had all played for the organization
before the teams were combined the
addition of peek-a-boo and tom brought
them to seven players on the roster for
spring 2015. this era started with some
quirks specifically with two of the
region's best mid laners on the same
roster faker and easyhoon having to
share time wait what's this what's this
i spy in the skt booth it's not faker
it's easyhoon and after a dominant win
in spring where faker didn't play in the
grand final the team fell to edg at msi
after faker's previously undefeated
leblanc was targeted by their chinese
opponents
for the first time
that i can remember
in a major international event of this
caliber all-stars season three world
championship
all-stars of the year but then the 2014
world championship
sk telecom taken down here by edwin
gaming in a thrilling series of events
but even so this was the golden era of
skt and one of the things that truly
characterized this roster was its
extreme depth fast forward to now and
it's less about those flashy plays and
more about
dominance on the map dominance in the
macro game they still have that same
level of individual skill but the
strategy has gotten much much better
through experience with a lot of these
players in 2015 and 2016 skt were the
greatest league of legends team in the
world hailing from the game's most
competitive region coup tigers are
falling skt will be your first ever
two-time world champions
sk telecom have overcome every challenge
they are the undisputed best team in the
world the skt reign continues they win
their third world championship three
world championships in four years two
back to back breakout stars that seemed
poised to continue a truly unprecedented
era of dominance i actually think that
2016 is super interesting because the
mara faker show was just basically them
just being way better at the game you
know this was also the height of bengi
being extraordinarily powerful at that
point in time as well i think that he'd
really come into his own in 2015. but
everything eventually ends and when it
ended for skt it hurt the upset is
complete as the kills come through the
skt dynasty is over all hail the new
kings samsung galaxy your 2017
world champions
worlds 2017 saw the skt dynasty come to
a crashing halt for a team that came
second at worlds that might seem like
dramatic framing but things were about
to get a lot worse
[Music]
peanut and huni left along with their
head coach c carter and they added some
promising young players but a
disappointing 1-5 start in spring for a
historical low of ninth place turned
heads immediately all the members of skt
have to go running to the hell speaker
goes with assault with designers
hourglass trying to keep himself alive
and in the fight but he's just too damn
low he'll get spat out goes back to the
fountain mvp they have done it not only
do they break the losing streak they go
to game three versus sk telecom t1 and
they defeat them in a match for the
first time since they have joined the
lck
i was not willing to ride off sk telecom
for this series in particular because it
seemed irresponsible they are still skt
they still do have the best player to
ever play the game and yet mvp won after
swapping blossom in as their jungler
they managed to qualify for playoffs
where an old rival was waiting for them
in quarter-finals kt rolster they've
done it it's the 3-1 victory in the
telecom war of the playoffs and they're
heading to round two kt rolster
eliminate sk telecom t1 at their lowest
position in the history of the lck
unfortunately summer showed exactly
where skt ranked in the lck nowhere near
the heights of 2015 and 2016. after an
8-10 summer split and a near miss in
regional qualifiers skt miss worlds for
the first time since 2014. the question
finally has an answer can skt still make
worlds sadly for you fans out there of
skt the answer is no that error is over
and the korea curse when it comes to skt
making it to a domestic world
championship does extend worse still as
china took home the summoner's cup on
korea's home turf no lck team made it
past quarters there were good korean
teams that were not named sk telecom t1
but they failed against both china and
disastrously north america at worlds if
the region was to bounce back in 2019
surely faker would need to be part of
that resurgence so skt shelled out for
talent in 2019 bringing together a
roster that on paper was absolutely a
super team two rising prodigies in khan
and cleared joined journeyman a.d carrie
teddy and critically the organization
signed mata arguably the greatest
support in the region's history what
they did
with skt which i think that no one
really could have expected because i saw
that roster uh on paper when we were you
know even in kesper cup before that
right and i was like holy crap can you
ever beat like
this team
um but what we failed to really realize
was that a team is more than just the
sum of its parts right and if you put
way too many chefs in the kitchen the
kitchen will just be on fire and full of
yelling the roster was reminiscent of
the skt that won back-to-back worlds
strong depth with carry potential in
multiple lanes in the event that enemies
focused on shutting faker down and in
the event that faker wasn't shut down
well he was still faker and that's the
one for one trade now for id the flight
from faker is insane do you think it's
the free hit and ig unseparated toward
faker can't get through it flip through
the spectacular over the wall it's
jackie two
korea fills it and spica filled the
whole damn play it's another fight in
the top side baker gonna go 1v3 at this
point as he still has his ultimate takes
out two
and we'll be going here on to on fleek
nice knock-up but still this is an echo
and you know the party never ends if
you're an echo player as another kill
comes down and skt with the baron will
push the hits they don't have kick here
though oh but that is going to land
though as the flash away from faker but
does oxley cover up damage no the one
last turret shot is gonna kill him but
while the team did well in spring there
was another team that seemed poised to
take the korean crown griffin they were
a new wave of stars including their hot
shot mid laner shovey whose breakout
performance that year built incredible
hype around the team and it was griffin
who were waiting for skt at the end of
the playoff bracket in both splits too
spring often does this to us gentlemen
we often get the quick ones
in the early stages of the year but this
is one that i don't think anyone
expected
skt 3-0
over griffin after their incredible
first round robin and what a way to end
the game skt gonna sweet griffin
here into the dumpster and they are
going to do it skt
will sweep in the playoffs and take down
every single team in their path they are
the most dominant team from the korean
region it's hard to feel bad when you
win playoffs in both splits and earn top
seeding for your region at worlds but
even from atop the standings skt in 2019
must have felt there was a younger
hungrier generation of players waiting
to break through behind them while
people look at skt and you know remember
of ghosts of korea past and in some way
they are the last bastion of hope of the
old generation of lck players we have
down bone gaming coming in we have
griffin coming in we have a lot of these
newer young gun players who don't
necessarily have that baggage of korea's
misfires in the past year and a half two
years still dam 1 and griffin were both
inexperienced internationally bowing out
in quarter finals against eu and chinese
teams it was now up to skt to keep
korea's world's dream alive but standing
in their way was g2 europe's greatest
roster
will only collect one and wonder is
still living g2 are coming out on top of
the fight for now but a beautiful body
slam will not be enough there is a pitch
that is not where you want to be against
desire and skt they've got nothing left
in this game one no flash no heal no
awful once it has to back up cool down
if you like drake the void
[Applause]
and just like that in an instant the
series is defined as g2 move to match
point can he get it done he can't the
vladimir
they can't do it this is it the greatest
team in the history of league of legends
taken down by the greatest team europe
has ever produced
fbx get ready g2 is heading to paris
skt one's lost at g2 was a defining
moment for league of legends korea was
no longer on top now with china
solidifying their place as the strongest
region and so sk telecom t1 now
rebranded as t1 went back to the drawing
board
[Music]
compared to 2019 it was an almost
complete breakdown faker teddy and
effort stayed but 2020 saw massive
changes to the t1 lineup it was a move
towards cultivating young talent around
the newly resigned faker now in his
seventh year with t1 and those young
talented players absolutely
rose to the occasion
and that is gonna do it t1 are your lck
spring 2020 champions now with a ninth
domestic title in the trophy case faker
and his new crew looked to repeat in
summer but he couldn't make that happen
he's gonna be absolutely fine the second
and last nexus turret is taken down
mystic flashes on forward death defy is
not enough and africa are gonna perform
the miracle they'll knock t1 out in the
wild card there was a lot on his mind he
was supposed to be helping to develop
these players while also being the
superstar who won three world titles and
so at the end of july t1 began benching
faker in favor of his mid lane
substitute closer in fact faker played
only a single game for the remainder of
the season closer was doing a great job
and according to t1's coach kim he and
faker were on essentially the same level
at the time but things were much clearer
and karma was faker on the sideline and
even though closer was doing well some
fans weren't happy about faker being
benched t1 ceo joe marsh even had to
post a statement about threats that the
organization had received but if some
fans were upset with the arrangement
more were about to join them their
lackluster finish in summer playoffs
meant a trip to the regional gauntlet
and even though faker did play it wasn't
enough to get back to worlds shipping
comes in and gumi uc is in the front
line for no reason ghost down not able
to stand up to the power that is genji
really nice combo shockwave coming in
but it doesn't look like it's gonna
matter they get pulled in and genji will
be making it to the world championship
of 2020 with the 3-0 sweep over t1 now
the question was simply how skt would
approach the future
[Music]
[Music]
adding support carrier from dragon x was
an important step but t1's development
team hadn't been idle either with bot
lana gumiyushi and jungler owner joining
the main roster after spending time as
trainees though they both had to compete
for a starting spot after a mediocre
spring the roster made it all the way to
the summer finals where they lost to
damon by this point owner and gumiyushi
had emerged as the clear starters in
their roles and with everyone playing
beside him at least four years younger
faker helped them find the path to
worlds see what he can do trying to
clear the wave he has the core drinker
and he will stay alive and we got
response coming in here but vista just
died the call is to just take down the
nexus and it looks like t1 will in fact
secure the third place seed from
the lck
t1 was back at worlds faker was back at
worlds the group stage showed that t1
was for real they split their two games
against china's first seed edg and swept
the other teams suddenly it seemed like
anything could happen and after blowing
out korean fourth seed hanwell life
esports t1 needed to defeat dan juan to
advance the only team with a perfect
group stage and defending world
champions when the two teams faced off
fans got one of the best five game
series in world's history
coming from that doesn't do anything in
the face of the zen zou ultimate and now
leaping in he smells blood in the water
that's the double kill that will be
match point for t1 against don juan kia
so much damage on dakaria t1 they fight
well to bring us to match point but
they'll get knocked down in game four t1
holding on for as long as they can but
they know this one is over and don juan
kia will bring us to game five when it
matters most you will find this fight
but usually standing strong on the back
side it does not matter and the face of
the elder darwa kia will wipe t1 off the
map they're gonna tp top as well they
have the elder dragon they have a wave
they have everything they need to go
into the world finals and damn old
legends and old legacies goodbye faker
goodbye t1 hello dom juan and show maker
they will defend their title in the
finals and look to go back to back sure
it wasn't another championship but this
team had nearly zero international
experience besides of course faker they
had so much room to grow and it wouldn't
take long to see them assume their
ultimate forms academy top laner zeus
was promoted to the starting roster but
otherwise the 2021 offseason was the
quietest in t1's recent history they
already had the pieces they just needed
time over the course of the 2022 lck
spring split t1 achieved something that
seemed unlikely to ever happen in this
highly competitive league a perfect 18-0
match record during the regular season
now nexus turrets will go down t1 an
absolutely historical moment 18-0 for
the first time in the lck and they tie
2015 summer skt and dom 1 2020 summer
two teams that then went on to win
worlds at plus 29 points in the season
and they dominated the playoffs as well
taking out second place gen g in four
games owner will be able to pick it up
and that is going to be the end of this
t1 are your spring 2022
victors
here at kintex once again for the 10th
win
of this organization
[Music]
faker had played with many different
teammates since he held his head in his
hands in 2017 he had missed worlds twice
he had struggled to get t1 back to where
his fans expected but now along with his
team he had finally succeeded t1 haven't
won worlds yet but for the first time in
a long time that seems possible the
young roster is developing alongside the
single greatest player in league history
and they all wear the uniform of the
game's most successful org building
something that stands the test of time
is the very definition of a dynasty
doing it a second time would be
unprecedented but if t1 pulls it off
we'll be glued to the screen
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification bell for unique
bite size videos you won't find anywhere
else hit us up on our twitter instagram
facebook and tick talk